my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone and welcome to
florida maybe
it's a weird setup that i have here i
hope it works this is a gaming q a i
also do personal q as but they are now
going on a different channel i now have
a channel for everything that is sort of
like not
nerd stuff i'll leave a link in the
description if you want to go do that so
now only gaming q a's on this channel
which means that if you want to leave
questions for the next one it will be
about gaming it will be next month you
can leave them below first question is
from neo notes and it says do you think
xbox fans should be concerned about the
lack of xbox games coming out this year
and the value of game pass um let me
tackle the second half of that first the
value of game pass if you're worried
about the value of game pass
because
now star field and uh red fall aren't
coming out you would just cancel your
subscription right
we're talking about like if if you were
specifically
subscribe to game pass for those two
games then you should just cancel your
subscription i don't believe it has any
kind of long term lock-in or anything so
if at any point you aren't happy with
game pass you would just unsubscribe
that part is solved
for the rest of it um this does happen
somewhat often with a new
console generation and obviously code
plays into it too where we don't get
a lot of uh big releases
i feel like actually considering the
circumstances playstation and nintendo
have just done
so much better than you would have
expected and for how how many studios
does microsoft just have now it's like
23 or something that they have
uh they have had a lot of delays they
have had some issues at certain studios
like some production management issues
by the sounds of things and there isn't
really a timeline of when
more bigger aaa games or games for me
studios will be coming out
in any solid ground but to answer the
question if it is do you think xbox fans
should be concerned about lack of xbox
games coming out this year it's
twofold one wait to their e3 conference
uh we don't even really know what's
gonna happen yet you should at least
wait until i guess it's not e3 anymore
but the upcoming xbox bethesda showcase
i would at least wait for that so that
you at least know
kind of what the next 12 months looks
like but the second is it's like almost
awkward to answer this question
do i think xbox fans should be concerned
i feel like it's just individual i think
if you're concerned if you're asking if
you should be concerned
it would depend on who you are and what
you care about and why
like i've seen some people take this so
so far that they were like oh this is
bad news for microsoft sony needs a
competitor xbox is going to shut down
which is ridiculous that is ridiculous
do you know how much money microsoft has
it's unfathomable amounts of money they
have so much money
xbox is not going to shut down
i assure you
when their revenue is going up year over
year even if they don't have any aaa
releases game pass is making them a [ __ ]
ton of money subscription services are
so good because often even when people
aren't using the service they forget to
unsubscribe so if the question isn't my
concern that xbox is going to shut down
no
no i don't think anyone needs to be
concerned about that the one thing that
concerns me on the broader interest
industry scale not just xbox is the
scope of aaa gaming is just getting so
[ __ ] big that the delays keep
happening or bugs keep happening it's
like one or the other you delay
for a long time or you launch buggy the
scope of these games is just getting
too big for the industry to handle it is
tremendous
because
even when you have a delay for say a
year or whatever
that doesn't actually remove crunch in a
lot of cases i know some studios say
that it does i doubt that that's true
um and in some cases no it's not true
that they delay and then crunch just
continues and these people are just so
fried by the end of development that
they can't even perform as well as they
would be able to otherwise i don't know
it's so nuts to think about how some of
my favorite games ever made like
rare nintendo 64 games were made by
tiny teams in a year and often they were
working on multiple at once like they
were working on banjo two in goldeneye
at the same time do i think xbox fans
need to be concerned about xbox closing
down no
do i think you have a right to be upset
if you're a fan of these games and you
bought an xbox with the hopes of like
getting you know staggered releases
there was no guarantee that you would
ever really get set releases it's always
a projection so it's like i think you're
right to be upset but um
it's kind of an inevitability of buying
into any new hardware as you don't
really know what it's going to look like
the thing that i think is more
concerning is the scope of aaa has just
gotten
so [ __ ] huge i don't really know if
it's sustainable
for the humans actually working on the
things in some of these cases especially
when you're making a big open world game
which both red fall and starfield are
but no xbox is not going to shut down
the value of game pass
is like up to you personally if you want
to subscribe or not obviously and there
are so many video games out there
that two games not coming out this year
in my head is like a win
got a lot of [ __ ] i want to catch up on
it is time to talk about keeps keeps is
a subscription service that helps men
keep a hair there is of course no magic
cure for boldness but you can prevent
hair loss from happening in the first
place keeps offers clinically proven
treatments to combat the symptoms of
hair loss the treatments are fda
approved doctor recommended and
delivered right to your door that's
right with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor's office or pharmacy they're also
affordable your daily supply of
treatment arrives every three months and
at half the cost of a pharmacy all
treatment plans are personalized and
doctor recommended and keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality each treatment plan actually
comes with a full year of unlimited
messaging so you can connect with your
prescribing doctor about anything at any
time so you don't even need to go
anywhere to get started you can easily
subscribe to keeps and get refill
reminders so you'll never run low on the
products you need to take care of your
hair hair loss stops with keeps to get
50 off your first order go to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash alana pierce
keith said hey lana just wondering how
often when you're a journalist were you
directed to write things specifically
for seo like did you ever get told
specifically to write something with
buzzwords in mind so that it would get
traction this is a great question
um
so the answer is always and never
but you love that i
as a writer at ign
and a producer at ign was always trying
to write something that was to do with a
trending game that was in part because
that's what i cared about because i as a
gamer also care about the video game
trends but yeah your your articles or
whatever will also just perform better
and more people will care about the more
people will read them which is like the
purpose of your job so i was never told
at any point ever
hey can you say something negative about
this so that we could get clicks i
actually not once while working in ign
ever looked at the traffic to my
articles i knew if they did super well
because um one of the people in the
editorial team looked i don't even know
if he really had to but he did and so
sometimes something i wrote would like
get to the front of our gaming or
something like that like it'd be on the
front page of reddit and obviously that
stuff you know that it's done well um
because it has trended just outside of
the website itself but i never
wrote things with the intention of
getting clicks in a way that i'm
assuming you're asking like i never
wrote things that were overly negative
or overly positive
uh in an interest of clicks ever i did
however always and still do this this is
what i do on youtube effectively i'm
always talking about trending games or
trending video game topics because
that's what i'm interested in that's
what the audience is interested in and
that's my job so i don't think there's
anything um very sinister at play
there or at least i never felt like that
was the shadiest thing i ever
encountered when i was working in aegean
i don't think i've ever told this story
before in terms of ethics was um this is
going to be really hard to explain
actually there's an editorial department
which is the people who write and make
the videos generally and then there's
like the sales department and the two
are extremely separate they do not talk
so the ads that you see on the front
page of ign the writers don't even know
that they're there so i've like had
conversations with people where they've
been like oh but these ads are on the
front page and then the game got got a
10 out of 10. you can't tell me that's
not related the two parties literally
don't even know like the the writer who
wrote the 10 out of 10 review would not
have even seen those ads not ever known
that they even existed because they
don't see that version of the site
they're so so so separate so
the sales team
can come to the editorial department and
say hey
could you write about this and it's
usually like a
very vague thing that they have sold for
an advertiser it's like a
we want you to write a top five toys and
just somewhere in the article you'll
feature an ad about cheez-its
or some [ __ ] that doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with toys but this
happened rarely but the editorial team
has sold
some kind of piece of content goes to
the writers and is like hey we need this
uh and none of that was ever positive
about a video game were negative about a
video game it was usually like a list
type article that would then have ads in
it sometimes videos um which would
usually be like i did a
thing that was sponsored by ea that was
about um star wars battlefront cosplay
so it could be stuff that's like
adjacent there was a cheez-it
sponsorship for one-two switch they were
like we're gonna just feature cheez-its
and you're gonna play a bunch of one-two
switches like a tournament so it was
always very silly stuff that never
pertained to saying if a game was good
or bad but was about the game so like
technically the ea thing was sponsored
and i had written like exclusively
really negative articles about star wars
battlefront 2 i had roasted it on the
daily fix i think the feature that i
wrote about how bad the monetization was
would the video would still be up of me
being like it's really bad
they still sponsored me um as part of
ign to talk about cosplay and again
those two things didn't overlap at all
because i was never asked to say
anything positive about the game i was
just asked to talk about cosplay which
is totally separate so the shady one was
they accidentally had to tell me who a
sponsor was
so i had been told to make these three
videos where i spoke about like five
pillars of
virtual reality and i knew that that was
from the sales team but i didn't know
who the sponsor was i just knew you make
these three videos you're gonna talk in
one about games that reduce motion
sickness in one about
games that have good open worlds and
then one about good combat something
like that i don't really remember and i
went through and i was picking these
games to write these scripts so that i
could make these videos for whoever the
sponsor was and at some point somebody
came to me and said hey
in this combat one have you seen this
game and i was like i have not seen that
game no and so they were like cool just
wanted to ask and then i went and
checked that game out and i was like oh
i actually could put this game on this
list um and i was not it was not implied
to me at any point
that that game was sponsored it seemed
like the person was asking me very
casually so then i was like oh i might
put this game on this list and i was
called into a meeting room because they
had to be like hey we asked you if you
had seen this game and you said no so
when we spoke to the sponsor and they
wanted you to include that game we had
to have a fight with them saying she's
never heard of it we can't push it on
her that would breach this ethics policy
so we cannot even tell her
now
to put it in she said she hadn't heard
of it we can't force it no
so that it so because of that because
they had had a fight that i knew nothing
about because that's what the sales team
does and how they protect the editorial
team when i was like i'm going to
feature this game they were like you
cannot [ __ ] feature this game we've
just had a fight with them about how you
wouldn't do it so you coming now and
saying that you're going to do it is so
not worth it it we have to walk all this
back we can't do any of that and that
was it i was told that i couldn't write
about a game because of some
relationship with sales where the
sponsor wanted me to sales protected me
and then i came back was like i could do
it i hope that thanks a good picture
that that was the single
least ethical thing that i ever felt
happened to me while i was at ign was
that i was actually tangled in what
sales wanted me to write about and i
couldn't write about something i wanted
to write about because of the sponsor
wanting me to and them fighting them on
it originally the only other one was uh
one time i wrote an episode of the daily
fix it was about metal gear survive and
i was very very negative
about um a release trailer for metal
gear survive that trailer was an ign
exclusive
so
the person who had that exclusive which
i don't think i even knew the person who
got that exclusive came to me and was
like
you can keep the video you have to
change this negative headline
we're the ones who got the trailer and
so i went you don't get to talk to me
about this
i have to be completely honest in all of
my opinions i will have nothing to do
with any of this take it to the
executive editor you can talk to them
about what they want to do about this
headline i will not change anything
because this conversation should not be
coming to me i'm supposed to be separate
from it and so they did i don't know if
they changed it i think they did change
the headline uh from what i had
originally written to something that was
like more boring even though what i had
said was very negative that's it those
are the two uh things that happened at
ign where i felt like i was like in
breach
of the sales versus writer relationship
and i again i hope that that paints a
good picture of
how that stuff actually works this is
probably like the most explicitly
anybody's ever spoken about this on
youtube
is like those are the two things if
there is some kind of conflict with the
sales department or with some exclusive
[ __ ] as a writer i should know nothing
about it and never be told about it
because i should always have the freedom
to write whatever i want and that's how
it always worked um
yeah those are the two i don't even know
how i devolved into this this isn't what
you are so just
hopefully you find this interesting
andrew howard said hey alana quick
gaming question for you are there any
australian game developers that you
think are producing great work is there
any aussie dubs you'd like to work with
one day love your videos on inside keep
up the great work cheers um there are so
many so so so many my friend
for recent games um
check out unpacking
i played the whole thing on stream no i
think i finished it off stream uh and it
is set in my hometown of brisbane which
was really really cool i went up to them
at gdc after they won a few awards it's
witch beam studio and was just like oh
man
that was i've never seen my hometown
represented in a game before that's nuts
uh untitled goose game previously highly
award-winning australian game um and
there was a game from the recent
nintendo direct the indie direct uh
called wayward strand from ghost pattern
i believe their name is that looks a lot
like sleep no more which is a theater
thing in new york i would say most
people who know anything about game
design know what sleep no more is
um i immediately reached out to them i
was like this looks super cool if
there's anything i can do to help i feel
like there's always one just absolute
[ __ ] banger australian game that
comes out every year and i'm so proud of
them um
for studios specifically i love league
of geeks
i've known a bunch of people who've
worked there throughout various
iterations
across the years you might know them for
armelo
um but it seems like they also just have
a really good culture and a really good
vibe and everybody really likes working
there oh of course um
francis vendetti uh great escape artful
escape of vincent vendetti i think
that's what it's called
i don't remember
that was australian made came out last
year also awesome um and then the last
one i'm very excited about summerfall
studios working on stray gods i have a
whole bunch of people i love who are
working on that game
uh i suspect it is going to be a pretty
tremendous critical success so
definitely worth checking out
lots of great aussie games they they
just kill it compared to like the size
of the country
the caliber of games coming out of the
tiny game dev scene is so good all right
one more question we've already been
going for a while croquevius gator it's
a question for gaming are there any
games that have been saved for you
because a minor patch is basically small
fixes not total overhauls like halo
master chief collection or no man's sky
my example is the final fantasy 12
remastered before job choices were
permanent which made me get hung up and
second guess myself each playthrough
with the release of the switch version a
feature was added across all platforms
that allowed a respect option respects
are huge um mine a lot of people
disagree with or at least i know some
people who disagree with i don't know
how many
i just know people personally
dragon's dogma darker risen i way
preferred a dragon's dogma and the
reason for that is the fast travel i
love love love dragon's dog modakaris
and it's so [ __ ] good and uh it was
in this area where capcom just kept
releasing the same game with a slight
difference year after year they just
kept doing it it's crazy to me that we
like let capcom do that
it was like marvel vs capcom 3 and then
another marvel vs capcom 3 with just
like a few more heroes that could have
just been free dlc darkerisn and
dragon's dogma not different enough for
two [ __ ] game releases capcom okay
but
i tried dragon's dogma and fell off fell
in love with dragon's dogma darkerism
because it has fast travel you get not
that the first doesn't but in
in darker risen you get more of these
crit i think it might even be unlimited
uh crystals that let you fast travel and
it just meant that i stopped bouncing
off the game basically i've been
tweeting recently about how if you like
eldering you should play
dragon's dogma
probably do dark arizon but you really
should [ __ ] it's good it's so good it
does a whole bunch of like very creative
stuff like the pawn system
just so good
alrighty everyone that is it from me
today uh if you want to leave questions
for the personal q a you'll have to go
over to the personal channel now it'll
have its first video up tomorrow the
personal q a will probably go up just
like any time in the month now because
it's not i'm not trying to separate the
two of them that much i'm excited to
make content over there excited to keep
gaming content up here and um sorry if
the audio is bad or the setup's terrible
doing my best tampa florida i'll see you
guys next time bye